So, what advice would you give to people just starting out?
I would say do not wait for a perfect moment.
You have so many tools at your fingertips, just go for it.
My dad had to close the doors of the family bakery, and I wanted to rebuild that business.
But in order to make this thing last, I had to learn about...
...some of the things my dad didn't have.
Our kids bought us a quilt machine and asked me if I wanted to do tutorials,...
...and I was like, sure honey, what's a tutorial?
Now, we're at 300,000 subscribers.
I had some experience in computers, but what I needed was a direction.
I took the class that taught me the basics of how to get the business online.
That was where I started reimagining myself.
I'm an entrepreneur, I can do this.
Whether you're a teacher, a business owner,...
...or just want to take the next step in your career,...
...you can find free tools and training to grow your skills...
...at google.com/grow.